it's official the Las Vegas Skyline will  look a little different and it will now  feature check this out a giant guitar  pretty cool right well the Nevada Gaming  Control Board officially approved the  Hard Rock purchase of the Mirage  property this morning well this comes a  year after MGM Resorts announced its 1  billion dollar sale of the property now  it will also come with a total  rebranding featuring a new pool Villas  private gaming rooms and animal habitats  this historic acquisition by such an  iconic brand will Mark a new era for the  Mirage and for this trip as we  demonstrated to the GCB and we'll now  show you the Mirage will be in good  hands as it becomes part of Hard Rock's  already amazing portfolio  well the Hard Rock says they will be  welcoming a team of 3 500 members to the  new property